the surge of the omicron variant not
only affecting people on the ground but
also those trying to get in the air to
visit loved ones for the christmas
holiday
hundreds of flight cancellations in the
united states united and delta two of
the largest carriers accounting for the
most
united sending out these alerts to
passengers your flight is canceled due
to an increase in covid cases limiting
crew availability we were really
concerned last night when i saw on the
news that they had cancelled 100 flights
and i'm like oh my god we won't be able
to get home
but luckily we kept checking the flight
status checking the flight status got
here and everything was fine so we were
really grateful for that
at new jersey's newark liberty airport
passengers mostly were trying to remain
calm i'm a little bit worried about
cancellation
so we see what happens i hope my flight
ain't canceled
i got the
you know all the vaccines three of them
and uh i got a mask nothing to worry
about
we're ready to go
that's it
all good
while omicron is surging so too is
holiday travel officials say more than
two million people passed through
airport security screening in one day
more than pre-pandemic holiday travel in
2019
airport workers say they are feeling it
just nonstop work
other times like we get
we get a long break
it's just non-stop work non-stop
holiday season yes holiday
it's crazy
i never knew it was like this
aside from the check-in counters the
longest lines at newark airport were at
the covid testing facility
and airlines in the u.s are already
starting to cancel more flights for the
days ahead and with the omicron variant
not expected to peak for at least
another couple weeks it likely will mean
more cancelled flights
especially if the flight attendants and
pilots who operate them
continue to get infected
gabriel zondo al jazeera newark new
jersey